tonight on Brian Ross investigates the
very latest on the corona virus and a
credibility gap between what the experts
say and what the president says because
of all we've done the risk to the
American people remains very low blaming
the news media and the Democrats for
causing panic
it looks like the corona virus is being
weaponized as yet another element to
bring down Donald Trump we're joined by
the former CIA station chief in Beijing
and by the Harvard professor who warns
that presidential bluster is no answer
to this growing threat with no person
plus a troubling update on the two
Americans suing the royal family of the
Arab Gulf state of Qatar he felt that he
can do whatever he wanted and he did now
the Libyan girlfriend of one of the men
Matthew a nd has been brutally attacked
is there a connection the victims
boyfriend will be here to make the case
plus our shoutout big news in South
Carolina but it's not the presidential
primary it's the indictment of one of
the state's powerful sheriffs and the
investigative reporter who first exposed
it from the law and crime Network
studios in New York City's Herald Square
this is Brian Ross investigates
good evening and welcome tonight as the
world braces for more bad news about the
corona virus there are new questions
about the ability of the United States
to effectively deal with the issue given
a credibility gap between what the
president and supporters are saying
about the severity of the threat and
what his own experts have said who to
believe who to trust
as if all we've done the risk to the
American people remains very low now
it's not so much a question of if this
will happen anymore but rather more a
question of exactly when this will
happen and how many people in this
country will become infected and how
many of those will develop severe or
more complicated disease hopefully we're
not gonna have to spend so much because
we really think we've done a great job
in keeping it down to a minimum
and again we've had tremendous success
tremendous success beyond what people
would have thought it looks like the
corona virus is being weaponized as yet
another element to bring down Donald
Trump so who to trust and to get a
reality check in all this we're joined
now by randy phillips the former CIA
station chief in beijing and now vice
chairman of the American Chamber of
Commerce in China and from Harvard a
public health expert dr. Margaret
Bordeaux of the Kennedy School Belfer
Center and dr. bow don't let me start
with you
this is spreading you trust I take it
the CDC not the president saying
everything is great yes has really grown
since we last spoke both numbers coming
from the CDC and also the World Health
Organization about the estimations of
the severity of those of the disease and
those infected and showing it to be
quite substantial and so just to just
say anytime you have a new virus on your
hands you have to assume that your whole
population can be susceptible and so if
your whole population is susceptible
and the mortality rate is you know as
high as some of the people in the World
Health Organization and CDC are
predicting you really need to focus and
realize we have a we have a real issue
on our hands here
Randy Phillips let me ask you the stock
market has been dramatically dropping
this week because of concerns about this
coronavirus in China how are they
handling it do you trust the Chinese
government be telling us and the world
the truth about what they're doing what
we saw under SARS in 2003 the it was
pretty little bar said at that time and
I recall very vividly at that time being
in the US government then having to deal
with a variety of issues related to
Americans and others being affected by
this lack of transparency that was only
overcome pretty late into the process
the Chinese government has been a little
bit better this time around
but it's still there's a tremendous
level of cynicism on the part of the
Chinese populace as well as the American
business community in China that we are
getting the true numbers and that hasn't
been helped by the fact that the Chinese
authorities have actually changed the
definition of how they define a case
several times over the last couple of
weeks and so at this point there is
still a level of concern that we are
getting the true numbers but it balance
has been better than what we saw the
last time around all right a question
now from our control room from executive
producer Rhonda Schwartz Rhonda doctor
Bordeaux thousands of people get the flu
all the time who is most vulnerable here
and why is it so much more serious yes
so that right every year we have folks
that and get seasonal flu the thing
about seasonal flu is that your whole
population isn't susceptible some
portion if fed the vaccine others have
had a similar type of flu before so even
if they're exposed to it they don't get
sick this is a new virus and that means
that we have to assume our full
population
susceptible to it so we have to assume
that if we do nothing we do nothing that
everybody could potentially get infected
and some of the numbers that are coming
out of the World Health Organization are
saying that the fatality rate the number
of people who die if they are infected
is somewhere between 0.7 percent to 4
percent and that is a very substantial
number of people whose lives are at
stake here now I'm hoping every day that
more information will come out show that
that is not you know that that number is
inflated but until that happens we need
to take this extraordinarily seriously
and and really start preparing ourselves
for a major situation randy phillips
from your experience in the intelligence
community when people don't trust the
government don't trust what's being told
to them about the severity of this
that's a real issue and hard to solve
isn't it that's a huge issue that's
where i think it it goes beyond just
obviously the medical effects of what
we're dealing with here the doctor Berto
obviously covers quite well the severity
of the the medical issues at play here
but this also has a huge political
economic and social consequences here
that are only just beginning to play out
that the fact that in China in that case
there is already some very significant
cynicism over what we have seen in terms
of transparency from the government and
some extraordinary activity and social
media in China showing tremendous doubt
trust in the government and that they're
getting these straight facts if you
multiply that out in terms of other
nations and that are already starting to
deal with this in Italy in Japan in Iran
and you know that would and the US will
see how that all plays out but this is
being able to lean on your your national
leadership and to be able to count on
that you're getting the straight scoop
in terms of what is happening I mean
nothing gets the attention
somebody's mind more than hey I've got a
tremendous disease heading my way and
affecting my family and I really expect
my government to give me the straight
facts all right Randy Phillips and dr.
Bordeaux thank you so much for joining
us tonight appreciate it thank you
up next a brutal attack on a California
woman that her boyfriend says has
potentially serious political
implications tonight a troubling update
on a story we first brought you last
year about two Americans suing the royal
family of the Gulf State of Qatar the
royal family in the Mideast country of
Qatar is the third richest family in the
world but now two Americans who worked
for the royal family in Qatar are taking
them on in this lawsuit filed in federal
court in Tampa in particular taking on
the Emir's brother Sheikh Khalid Al
Thani alleged to be a heavy drug user
who ordered the murders of two
individuals in California who he viewed
as threats to his social reputation and
personal security one of the men suing
is Matthew petard of Tampa hired by the
Sheikh to be chief of security for his
family seen here in a promotional video
for a security company at the Sheikh
fountain he thinks he's a thug who's
beyond a pre on reproach and can go
after and do whatever he wants the other
American suing the Sheikh is Matthew a
Hyundai of Los Angeles a trained
paramedic brought in by Matthew petard
of the lawsuit says after the Sheikh
overdosed on opiates he had stopped
breathing his eyes rolled in the back of
his head at first both men worked for
the Sheikh while he was in residence in
California his entourage taking up an
entire floor of the Beverly Wilshire
hotel in Beverly Hills so drugs and
hookers were part of a regular routine
at the Beverly Wilshire hotel when he
was in residence there yes sir
[Music]
the shake was already well known to
police in Beverly Hills in 2015 he was
in the headlines
to be caught on video drag racing in a
Ferrari through the quiet residential
streets one man who lives on the street
almost got hit by one of these cars and
kids tonight tell me they're scared to
play on the streets business he and his
bodyguards at the time and tried to act
like tough guys with the man who made
the video get the caddy here did you
know that get out of my pocket I'm not
on your property I told him that in
America we have the free press and we
are allowed to film from the sidewalk
and he said F America and threw a
cigarette at me then the Sheikh later
claimed falsely that he had diplomatic
immunity to the outrage of the Beverly
Hills police chief
you can't claim diplomatic immunity if
you don't have it and you can't use that
as an excuse to jeopardize the public or
commit crimes they're the spoiled rich
kids of the Middle East that's what
that's what I viewed how I saw it he
bragged about the incident oh yeah you
know it's racing you know through the
streets they've gotten me on the news ha
ha ha you know that kind of thing
nothing was taken seriously he felt that
he can do whatever you wanted and he did
but things got much more serious petard
says when the sheikh gave him an order
to assassinate two individuals one man
one woman who he says the Sheikh
suspected were going to reveal his
secrets this male had compromising
photos of Sheikh at one of these parties
as well as some video and some other
things and so he wanted you to kill him
he told me I want you to go take care of
him what did that what did that mean
take care to kill him petard says when
he refused the Sheikh was furious he
said you're not a real marine you
disgust me get out of my sight and a
problem I got up and left that left the
suite but the pay was good at $100,000 a
year and both men traveled with the
shape back to Qatar as he moved into his
palace in the capital city of Doha the
to travel with him wherever he went
this video was shot by Hyundai in the
sheiks police motorcade to the country's
early National Day cell
raishin it wasn't long the two men say
before they grew tired of the Sheikh and
his shady associations and continued
they say drug use while in Qatar but
petard says the Sheikh threatened to
kill him if he left calling him disloyal
he called me on the phone and basically
said you backstabbing piece of poop can
I cuss on this you can bleep it out you
backstabbing piece of shit I'm gonna
fucking kill you bury you in the desert
and kill your family in the case of Ind
he says the Sheikh refused to let him
leave his compound so he had to try to
escape climbing over this 14 to 18 foot
wall I chanced it because I felt that
was a better alternative than being held
against my will I'm not gonna be a
prisoner to this man and I jumped
instant pain to the left side of my body
fell the rounds again they says he broke
his leg and guards caught him and
dragged him back inside the compound and
then ordered him to go to the sheiks
bedroom basically I've broken you you
know you can't if I don't want you to
and that's all he wanted to know is you
can't you wanted me to know rather it
was you can't go unless I say you can go
this man is corrupt and as soon as you
get over to where he's the law of the
land he can do whatever he wants
joining us now by Skype is Matthew
Allende and Matt what's the update it
seems very troubling yeah very troubling
indeed
unfortunately on January 14th I had came
home from work I had texted my
girlfriend that I was on my way out be
home at 6:00
I arrived at 6:45 a little bit late I'd
walked in the door nothing looked a mist
in the house I walked into the bedroom
and I saw her brutally beaten blood all
over the sheets the walls she was barely
conscious then apparently she had
declined in route to the hospital when
in critical condition
went into a coma and they informed her
mother which was there on her way from
the East Coast that she was not expected
to make it through the night
she
did make it through the police are
investigating and you think there's a
connection to the lawsuit that you filed
and your appearance here absolutely we
have to mention it we have to keep in
mind the premise of this lawsuit in the
first place
the lawsuit contains Matthew batard the
other person and the other plaintiff in
this case that he was asked by Prince
call it to murder a male and a female
while he was present here in the United
States but met you don't have any
evidence of a direct connection to the
Qatar royal family do you as of this
time we do not however even mind this
crime that occurred on the in the actual
home there was jewelry all over the
bedroom worth in the tens of thousands
of dollars actual large bills present
nothing was taken the police from
capacity and Police Detectives has
stated this this crime is very uncommon
especially for our higher-end residents
now by the way let me point out we at we
asked the Qatar embassy for a reaction
they had no reaction no comment at all
and the investigation is continuing and
you think it's going to point in the
direction of the retaliation because of
your lawsuit absolutely I have no doubt
this is a pattern of behavior of prince
college let me ask you finally how was
your girlfriend doing now as of this
time she is out of the hospital however
now she suffers from seizures because of
the brain damage she has a very hard
time doing simple math and she was a
corporate accountant all right so that's
Ling so she's very troubling very
troubling to hear all this and thank you
you please keep us posted as we continue
to follow this story absolutely I have a
feeling we are gonna get a lot more
evidence the detectives do have leads so
yeah I think that we're gonna find out
exactly what this was all about Matthew
then they thank you so much for joining
us tonight
appreciate you thank you up next our
shout out for the investigative reporter
in South Carolina covering a big story
not the presidential primary but the
indictment of one of the state's
powerful sheriffs our shoutout tonight
for a top investigative journalist in
South Carolina
Tony Barlow me while all eyes may be on
that state for the Saturday's Democratic
primary this journalist has been keeping
his attention on local politics and in
particular the alleged abuse of power by
some of the state's most powerful
elected officials it was a tip to a
local investigative reporter that led
this summer to prison time for powerful
South Carolina prosecutor Dan Johnson
reporter Tony bartoleme of the Post and
Courier in Charleston South Carolina
found the evidence he needed for his
story on the prosecutor in Johnson's own
expense reports nobody looked at him yet
nobody had sifted through them so I got
ahold of them and started looking
through them and a bunch of things just
immediately out including a $173
override in Minneapolis where bartoleme
used to live I thought you know I bet he
went to Prince's house on the Publix
dime and lo and behold that's exactly
what he did
and during that trip he also too spent
money on a major league baseball game
the twins and from there we started
looking into other things like trips to
the Galapagos Islands there's class
plane trips to all over the country and
and things like that
Bartel may who is the senior reporter on
the post and couriers investigative team
says they decided to expand their probe
into all official expense reports so we
thought what are other islands of
government in South Carolina that exist
on their own without much scrutiny and
sheriff's immediately came to mind and
so we basically we saw every spending
record we could get from every county in
the state all 46 counties suspended
Greenville County Sheriff will Lewis is
facing more charges tonight
among those highlighted
by Barah me was sheriff will Lewis of
Greenville County now facing criminal
charges that he was using public money
to carry on a sexual relationship with
an employee who has now claimed she was
raped he has denied the charges and her
claims her allegations that basically
forced her to have sex forced her to do
other things in and used that fear of
termination losing her job as a as a
cudgel next was the sheriff of Florence
County people who live in the area are
speaking out after the man they elected
sheriff Kenny Boone was arrested and
charged with embezzlement and misconduct
in office Sheriff Kenny Boone is also
now facing state charges as a result of
Bart amis reporting he too has pleaded
not guilty again it was all these these
these sort of questionable expenses for
personal gain the most serious charges
came following Bartleby's story on
sheriff alex Underwood Underwood had a
pattern of misbehavior ranging from
assaults he'd assaulted a couple of fire
chiefs at a traffic stop and also a man
was live streaming traffic wreck as the
man was streaming his video on Facebook
sheriff Underwood is seen approaching
him and can be heard challenging him
there was a scuffle essentially
Underwood and his deputies threw the guy
in jail cooked up a bunch of bogus
charges
and then tried to cover up when they FBI
began investigate sheriff Underwood is
now under federal indictment he has
pleaded not guilty to the charges when
we put it all together we produced you
know a very large package of stories
that really kinda captured the scope and
significance of and history of why
sheriff's have gotten into trouble
Bartleby says his editors no such
investigative reporting takes time and
money but that they have decided it
the only way local newspapers can
survive in the past few years we've
analyzed the data and we've found that
people are more likely to subscribe to
stories that are done with depth and
quality we found that the sheriff story
for instance generated the most
subscriptions of any story last year or
earlier this year on a local level it's
really the only way we'll be able to
survive and we are finding that
investigative journalism though it's
expensive is what keeps people reading
and now this month yet another South
Carolina sheriff has been indicted
Collins and County sheriff Andy
Strickland accused of embezzling public
money and using his powers a sheriff to
coerce an employee into a sexual
relationship he has pleaded not guilty
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week